hi I'm Erik Bosse and AB intercept fit
into worries making its way to viewers
around the world
exciting them and then bumming them out
but mostly leaving us with questions
about how these events will be resolved
in the next movie Avengers 4 with many
wondering specifically about dr.
Strange's mysterious moves in the movie
did this kind of a secret plan that we
didn't know about and yeah spoiler
warning to the dum-dums who clicked on
this video without seeing the movie
first you have to be at least to this
sad to watch the video ok if you're
still here you should know that infinity
war ended with Thanos succeeding and
going through with this plan to snap
half the universe out of existence this
includes half the good guys
spider-man here Black Panthers here
mantas oh right yeah her and Doctor
Strange who looks at Tony and right
before collapsing in a dryer lint says
Tony there was no other way and then
dryer lint strangest final words are
connected to a realization he had
earlier in the movie before their battle
with Diana's on Titan he uses the time
stone to look forward in time at 14
million 605 possible outcomes in their
upcoming fight he said that they only
win in one of those series of events so
yeah their odds against Thanos are
fourteen million to one but you know
what our reaction should be so you're
telling me there's a chance it's not
just that the odds against the anistar
so bad we should assume that all of dr.
Strange's actions from this point
forward are following the precise steps
of that path that he envisioned because
why bother fighting otherwise he could
just enjoy these final minutes of
existence over in that hands dimension
they touch everything so what a strange
do well at first dr. transplant seems to
be joining the others in a very creative
team-building exercise distracting
Thanos just long enough for the others
to surprise him and then using various
spells to try to separate the gauntlet
from his fists he grafts the cloak of
levitation around it as well as his
crimson bands of cyttorak and spider-man
almost wriggles that thing off but then
star-lord realizes that Thanos killed
Gamora to get the soul stone so he
Wallops his face and anger which breaks
everyone's hold strange confronts Thanos
one-on-one and then Iron Man tags in but
Fanus overpowers both of them so strange
bargains with Thanos trading the time
stone if Danis spares Tony Stark's life
then Thanos pieces out back to earth for
the final stone Tony asks strange why
and strange says we're in
the end game now and Tony's probably
like that Dana is my question
strange intended on Thanos getting the
time stone he knew it had to happen this
was all part of the one possible
successful outcome he envisioned the
attempt to get the gauntlet off his hand
and it failing either due to the general
sloppiness of the melee or people making
their own rash decisions as we saw
star-lord do see by endgame strange was
referring to chess the endgame of any
chess match is marked by the moment both
sides start to make major but necessary
concessions to close in on their
opponent you give up your queen or that
Knight you've always had a soft spot for
so that you can move forward in leading
the other side to their inevitable
defeat now these aren't random losses by
oversight or bad tactics these are
planned strategic sacrifices that hurt
but you've got to make him to get to the
W so that is what Doctor Strange is
doing by giving up the time stone he
knew from the moment he flipped the
pages to the end of this choose your own
adventure book that Thanos would end up
with all six Infinity stones no matter
what they tried but but but he needed to
make sure this battle went a particular
way first he needed thinnest to really
fight for the time stone in doing so he
allowed stark to learn that he could
draw blood for the mad Titan even if it
was just a drop to at least leave stark
with the hope that this guy isn't
invincible strange also needed certain
survivors to be left standing after
Thanos to snap Tony Stark and nebula he
prolonged the fight long enough for
nebula to join them on Titan and yeah he
ensured Tony Stark's survival in his
bargain both of these characters we can
assume have roles to play in the wars to
come Strange knows the purpose of the
mission isn't to prevent the apocalypse
it's making sure that Tony Stark this
John Connor here survives the apocalypse
to leave the survivors to an eventual
victory in the Infinity Gauntlet comics
that victory comes from nebula stealing
the gauntlet while Thanos is distracted
and rewinding time a day before
thanassis genocide oh snap later Adam
warlock negotiates a truth with Thanos
perhaps Avengers four will go that way
maybe with Tony swapped in as a
negotiator of course I could feel a
little cheap in the movie if they just
simply rewind the clock before everyone
faded away and bring everyone back with
no consequences but I doubt it would be
that simple I am willing to bet that dr.
strange did know that Thanos his snap
would be a one time
notice how the Infinity Gauntlet
appeared to be cracked and smoldering
after the snap
now of course Thanos could still use the
space stone in this moment to escape but
it's not clear if he could still wield
all six stones simultaneously and clean
up as savagely as he did in this movie
there's even an argument that Thanos
could have been part of the half caught
in a snap wave and that that realm he
was in with young Gamora meant a one
extra life given to him by the sole
stone with now spent whatever you make
of it it's safe to say that Thanos is
definitely weaker now really it's too
early to know how Santos could be beaten
but it's interesting to look at who will
be doing the beating dr. Strange's
decision led to specifically these six
og Avengers being among the survivors if
you count Hawkeye who is confirmed to
return in Avengers for sure this could
be part of Marvel Studios master plan to
end things how they began while taking
the MCU newcomers with their own likely
sequels out of the equation for now with
a later plan to bring them back and yeah
stay tuned to other Theory videos on
this channel we have on it subject but
narrative Lee speaking it's possible
that strange new the original six
Avengers possess a unique chemistry from
their past adventures and that if they
were properly motivated by the sting of
defeat that chemistry combined with
backup from war machine nebula rocket
Ocoee cherie wong baku ant-man and
captain freakin marvel could give them
an edge in their final mission because
let's be honest you can't truly be an
Avenger unless you have something to
avenge in this case happy for in Sternin
and to Dreyer went but I'm gonna throw
the question over to you guys do you
think Doctor Strange planned for Tony
Stark to survive or for all the
characters we saw survive to live I
guess I'm just wondering what exactly
was the vision Doctor Strange saw in his
time meditation was it Tony Stark locked
in a game of chess with Dan O's and like
Magneto and Professor X or a specific
line up of multiple heroes working
together against Thanos and some unique
synergy comment down below with your
theories or tweet me directly ID a vos
or follow new officers on Twitter for
updates on our videos like and share
this video and subscribe to new rock
stars for all of our deep dives and
analyses on the Avengers infinity war
guys thanks for watching bye